good morning John I spent last weekend
in Glacier National Park a place that is
dripping with scenic beauty and
absolutely no cell phone signals that
might have something to do with all the
extremely sharp cliffs and jutting rock
formations and a desired not to like
build cell phone towers on some of the
most scenic mountains in the world there
is a road it was completed in the 1930s
that bisects Glacier National Park
called the going to the Sun Road it's a
little bit terrifying as for a great
deal of the time especially on the way
up
you're basically driving three feet away
from a precipitous drop if you're in the
car and not driving there's this weird
sensation that you need to lean away
from the cliff even though obviously
that's not going to help anything if the
car goes over but you shouldn't lean
away from the cliff you should lean
toward the cliff because that's where
the best view is it's a little strange
that this road was even built it
continues to be an engineering marvel
because of avalanches and freeze thaw
cycles the road needs constant repair
and the road doesn't actually go
anywhere except to the top Logan Pass
which during the winter is regularly
covered in more than 80 feet of snow the
going to the Sun Road closes in
September and doesn't open again until
July it almost seems like a uniquely
American thing there's this beautiful
place but people can't get to it unless
they're ridiculously dedicated so let's
spend millions of dollars building a
miracle of a road in fact let's give it
a miraculous sounding name we have to
democratize access to this grandeur and
this beauty and these cute ground
squirrels in these majestic mountain
goats but you cannot snapchat them while
you're up there because your cell phone
doesn't work you have to wait until you
get back to your hotel room and then
when you get there you'll check the news
and find out that once again Donald
Trump has said something disgusting and
inexcusable that somehow hasn't
disqualified him from seeking the
presidency of this beautiful place
listen I'm not much of a nationalist
part of what I like about Glacier
National Park is that the ecosystem it
contains stretches between international
borders and into Canada's Waterton Lakes
National Park indeed a commitment to
being a proactive part of the global
systems on which we rely economically
socially and ecologically is part of
what I
love about being an American and I
really do love this country though that
gets harder during election years which
always highlight what I dislike about
being an American we work so hard to
demonize each other that everyone comes
out looking like demons and yes that
looks a lot worse this time around than
it did last time and yes I do feel
particularly discouraged but it's easy
to forget what this country has done
what we have built what it cost us and
how easy it is to be proud of it all you
have to do is not look at Twitter for a
few hours and instead look at what we've
built yes we have problems and yes it
makes sense that we spend a lot of time
discussing them because after all they
are the problems but god damn it if I
don't love this country even in the face
of the popularity of a despicable man
god damn it if I'm not proud to be an
American John I'll see you on Tuesday
this isn't a scary part okay I rode oh
yeah why drum put up a lot of cars oh my
god I'm gonna murder you
they did say that we should get off the
roads by a certain time Nance Hale yeah
it hailed a little bit get some hail oh
hey there
oh I missed it pooping wow you you don't
mind so much oh gosh you're cute oh gosh
you're a healthy-looking chipmunk oh
yeah how does a baby bison pooping
nobody poops guys the Chuck